have you found that there are some
topics for you that are off-limits is
there any topics for you that you feel
like I shouldn't really go there because
that's just gonna bum people out well I
don't think there's anything that's
off-limits but it's like how much gets
like dragged through like we've already
watched the news all day and like I
don't want to hear about that now yeah
like I'm like I mean there's so much
like that's that stuff that's obvious
like you know you want to talk about
white privilege and Pete a lot of people
don't think white privilege is real it's
white people but like I know firsthand
it's real because I have it it's great
but like I know I have white privilege
because I believe in ghosts and that's
what you get to believe in when you
don't have any other real problems like
Oh what about the disappearing middle
class what about poltergeists
poltergeists are out there also
yeah I'm fine it's a luxury very much so
yeah late at night covered my face so
your sakes breaking all my dishes and
bending my you're saying you're saying
only you think only white men can afford
to believe in the supernatural is that
what you're saying it's not it but I'm
like it's just like if I meet a black
guy that believes in UFOs I'm like
you're taking on a lot right now
[Laughter]
everything else you got to worry about
you throw an extraterrestrial that's
ambitious
we got so many terrestrial woes yes
also you got one guy getting you know
they get me every Thursday when I walk
home from the store yeah and nobody's
got any love for him third the community
meeting trying to talk about racial
profiling is like they suck me up in the
ship now Daryl we got real [ __ ] oh you
say black lives matter but I'm over here
dealing with this every Thursday's are
just weird for that guy and everybody
was talking to him about ocking to him
no one's talking to him my god well
guess what you got to see this guy live
this a hilarious you got to see him live
you can see Kyle live this Thursday
through Sunday at Cobbs comedy club I'm
sending you there this is an assignment
though okay yeah I gotta get on that
Southwest flight yeah Sunday at Cobbs
comedy club in San Francisco that's
Thursday through Sunday Cobbs comedy
club in San Francisco California at Cal
you're hilarious always hilarious thank
you so much
you